et le coc u19 amplifié à les inégalités
dans le monde ce sont en tout cas les
mots de la nouvelle chef d'amnesty
international une alerte lancée à
l'occasion de la publication récemment
du rapport annuel de l'om j'ai la
catastrophe sanitaire a profité à
quelques-uns et à exacerber les
situations de détresse et les tensions
sociales selon amnesty
un an de pandémie et un effondrement des
droits humains la nouvelle patronne
d'amnesty international a d'ailleurs
adressé un carton rouge à la france
en france l'espace de débat public
l'espace pour la réalisation des droits
civiques et politiques est en train
d'être réduit
comment pourquoi est ce que je dis ça
pourquoi est-ce qu amnesty international
dit ça tout d'abord parce que là le
droit de manifester a fait l'objet de
nombreuses restrictions au cours des
dernières années et en particulier au
cours de la dernière année
parce que les l'utilisation d'armes non
non létale par la police a créé à et la
cause des deux blessures
incroyable la loi de sécurité globale à
renforcer le pouvoir des forces de
l'ordre à imposer une forme de
surveillance a contraint les les témoins
les citoyens à arrah être beaucoup plus
sur leurs gardes
quand ils ont quand ils sont les témoins
de violences policières
il s'agit bien là d'un carton rouge il
s'agit bien là de dire attention les
derniers développements depuis depuis
quelques années en particulier en 2020
vont dans une direction qui est
extrêmement nocives problématique et
possiblement même dangereuse pour
l'ensemble des des droits et libertés en
phr